>>Richard: You're mom's outside,
your mom's right there, Madison.
>>Narrator: The CARE
for Kids initiative aims
to create supportive relationships
between Jefferson County
students, teachers and staff.
>>Principal: Hello, sweet girl,
you have a good day, okay?
>>Narrator: So everyone at
Breckenridge Franklin Elementary,
from the principal to the
janitorial staff, receives training
to become part of the
CARE for Kids team.
>>What's wrong?
>>Narrator: Security monitor, Richard
Little, shared his perspective
on the success of the initiative.
>>Richard: When I was going
to school, it was old school.
Boys and girls, all right,
they'd get paddlings.
That's when you come out
in the hallway and you turn
and face the hallway,
everything else is behind.
They got the paddle, and they
coming from here, swinging,
you know, maybe two or three.
It all depends on the
severity of what you done.
>>Yeah, I don't see him
yet, wait just a minute.
>>Education was real great because
you had people that cared, all right,
and nurtured you in school.
I loved it because the simple
fact is, you live right
in your own community, you know.
And so if I did anything that you
felt that I didn't need to do walking
down the street, you could
get me, and then my mom
and my grandma would get a telephone
call, then they could get me.
And the teachers could
get you, you know.
So it was always somebody that
were with you that nurtured you.
>>Stay together, see
you all tomorrow.
Have a good day.
>>And today we have a cell
phone, seven year olds
and eight year olds are
getting, and they're texting.
You know, they're on the computers
all day and all night, you know,
and so they really don't get
what they really need at home
because simple fact is, they've
got all this technology, all right?
Well, when they're in the
elementary school right here
in Breckenridge Franklin,
they get everything they need.
Everything they need, because you
have a staff here that's a family,
all right, and it's
not about a friendship,
it's about a relationship.
>>Stay over there with Page.
>>I was invited to a faculty
meeting, and on that particular day,
that's when they introduced
the CARE for Kids program.
And what overwhelmed me
was, they were talking
about children being left
behind, and I know how I grew up,
and how people cared
for us, you know.
I mean, anybody in the
neighborhood, it was like,
one child, one village, you know.
So I told them, I said, "You
know what, I like this program"
and I see this program that's
being implemented and it works,
because I was here and
I seen it for myself.
I seen things other parents
wouldn't be able to see.
>>My teacher teaches terrifically.
>>I like that alliteration too.
>>Richard: I know for a fact
that these teachers here are
doing everything they can
to keep these children from
being left behind, and they do it
because it's a mission for them.
And every child that walks through
that door, I guarantee them,
they're not gonna be left behind.
So whoever started this
program, I take my hat off
to 'em, because it works.
>>Richard: CARE for Kids works.
CARE for Kids will
work at any school,
as long as you got a great
staff and a great leader.
At the end of the day, those kids
getting on those buses with a smile
on their face, my job is done.
I can safely go home
and say, "You know what,
when they came this
morning, they had smiles,
and when they left they had smiles.
Our job is done, because we care."
>>Katrina, see you
tomorrow, okay buddy?
>>Narrator: For more
information about what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org